[Music]
how Gumba my name and welcome to well as
you can see I'm still in Italy and it's
pretty freakin hot as crucial I'm
basically gonna stay here over the
summer I don't know if I mentioned it in
the last video and it's my girlfriend's
house we're staying Elsa Bartha ride the
sugar I want to say thank you bros for
eight hundred son I can never say it I
couldn't even say any month eight
hundred thousand subscribers
Bruce whatever it really needs a lot i I
never thought I didn't think would ever
reach this much so I'm really happy
about it I hope I'm really ready Bruce
like the montage that I made to I really
worked hard on it
God dad that I grabbed that shed and
then hump it that I'm supposed to do a
lot of you bros wanted me to give you it
of the house and since it's not really
my house I don't really seem like a pawn
good point but sense
I can show you where I am when I sit at
least a little quick so let's cut the
pretty bad to the future here you go
all right so I realize this is a little
embarrassing but super high record it's
pretty much in my girlfriend's parents
guests rooms kitchen I know a lot of
people comment about this freaking sink
in the last episode like way to fire in
the bathroom done I mean a [ __ ]
kitchen but yeah there's mr. Schurr I
got a cheap as I share ever because I
broke the other one rest in peace out
there mr. chary this is my billboard I
like to have a billboard because I like
to keep my thoughts on somewhere
otherwise I don't get anything done I
also have a lamp I thought it was
necessary to lit it up to show the you
that if I can if I can help it it's it's
so you can see me in the dark pretty
much holy [ __ ] I got to talk fast
there's me editing a video there's my
logic take your webcam I like black
software and likes again I poke them too
here's my legendary headphones they're
starting to break I really don't want
them to break there's a Razer Mamba that
I got sent for me for free Thank You
Josh override racer for sending me three
stuff I like reset here's my beauty my
one and only oh you are so beautiful
Beth um I love you Beth done and we're
actually gonna open bet on Bethan has a
bunch of nerdy stuff in her I spent all
my money to buy this computer I was
with Broca's how to get started on
YouTube but it was worth every penny and
that concludes the setup job beautify
and it will end if I remember correctly
with a hairy leg let's see it that it is
a tie and Rick are back with beautify
from the past again I wanted to do a Q&A
quick I asked you us on Twitter ask me
whatever you want
so here we go all right Tiger gaming rut
asked me how often do you meet your fans
here in Italy it doesn't really happen I
don't think I haven't that many Italian
breasts I know I have a Coppa Italia
Brook but it's sweetened almost every
time I went out the door there was
always someone is there not a lot of
brothers knew where I lived too that
they were kind of stalking outside by no
other way Roby Lidia how do you have any
tips for how to egg for new let's
players I guess what's best and I make
videos because you think it's make
videos that you enjoy me and I think the
rest will come by itself I know a lot of
people seem to focus more on how to be
successful but first step is to make
sure you're actually enjoying the videos
that you that you're creating Marek and
may gem is there any new horror games
that you are looking forward to yes
there are actually a lot of horror games
coming out it's really good I'm really
happy to see that the horror John Rice
becoming more popular again among the
sleep looks really great you play like a
two-year-old I'm gonna sha machine a
machine for pigs like I showed in last
episode as tulum it's like a point of
quick game
what else shot him on the sole pretty
cool
yeah there's a lot of horror games
coming out and we have a lot of screams
coming up - Brooke that's good
I'm sweating like crazy here all right
then yard it'd be noisy yeah yeah I
think that's pretty good
have you ever sucked your own feet I
haven't I haven't done it and I probably
never will Lloyd Underwood are you found
of any sports uh yes I play tennis
yeah since I was a kid same with golf
pretty much but I don't golf that much
anymore
yeah all right tires are higher and my
sorry what and who inspires you to make
youtube videos right now I guess you
bros my fans you know that's what makes
it fun for me but started off I don't
remember who it was I just kept watching
random videos in YouTube and it seemed
like a fun thing to do
pretty much so I think any time this
video before I freaking die I want to
jump in the pool right away
hey pretty bro I have to get closer is
your locker you ready for - bro as
always thanks for all the support bros
stay awesome and here comes a broad-base
come on activate
I gotta do the pool jump gotta get naked